hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast primary motor and sensory
cortical areas communicate via
spatio-temporal e coordinated networks
at multiple sequences presented by dr.
fritzy RC Machane i'm susie valdez of
glabrous and i will be your moderator
for today's event we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning here's how this presentation
will work today we want to hear from you
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen will try
to get to everyone but if not we'll make
sure to follow up with you by email you
can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon on the lower
right hand corner of your slide window
if you cannot hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button at the lower
left this is an educational webinar and
this offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the c/e button located at the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process processing of
obtaining your credit I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. fritzy
RC McCain to the research assistant
professor at the Department of orgasmos
biology and add me at University of
Chicago dr. our speed machines
bachelor's degree was in physical
therapy her MA degree in motor learning
and her PhD in neuroscience her primary
research interest lies in elucidating
the neuronal mechanisms that underlie
sensory motor control and learning by
using electrophysiological recordings
from the sensorimotor cortex of behaving
non-human primates she has investigated
the sensory motor control of reaching
feeding and the coordination of arm
movements and posture her special
interest lies in understanding of the
functional connectivity between the
motor
and sensory areas of the cortex that
underlies sensorimotor integration I
will now turn over the presentation the
doctor Arsene machine welcome thank you
thank you Susie introduction hello
everybody thank you for attending this
webinar on the primary motor and sensory
cortical areas communicated by a special
semper to coordinate networks as
multiple frequencies I hope you enjoyed
this segment treszura motor integration
is important and necessary in learning
and performing motor skills you know
from the simple tasks of feeding we
should do every day to driving a car
playing tennis or even piano all of
these activities through our interaction
between sensory and motor processes that
takes place in our brain let's have a
closer look at it using this simple
diagram so we started as a school for
example I'm hitting a baseball and there
has been change in our body
configuration or in environment in order
to achieve the goal that we have at hand
so for this for this example we have
heating the baseball the motor cortex
which is involved in the production of
our movements will generate motor
commands to our muscles in order to
position our arm in a proper way to hit
the ball and then this movement will
cause a change in our in our body and
also in the ball over time to hit and
there's going to be a sensory feedback
as a consequence so this could be like
how fast we hit the ball or like the
strength of our grips the disposition of
the joints relative to each other so all
of this information will be sent to the
somatosensory cortex now there has to be
an exchange of information between the
motor cortex and the somatosensory
cortex in order for us to generate
efficient movement this exchange of
information is kind of like a
communication between soup cortical
areas
and we know that neurons do not function
in isolation they form assemblies and
networks and the outputs of neurons have
to be coordinated in time kind of like
what we call synchronization so
neuroscientist study interaction between
cortical areas in many ways and one who
get one of these ways is coherence
coherence is the cross correlation
between two signals in the frequency
domain so for example between spike
strains of two neurons or it could be
fight from one neuron and local field
potentials from another electrode that
were recording from and coherence has
been suggested to represent like the
coordination of the timing of synaptic
inputs to target neurons so here for
example on this slide we see the inputs
from one neuron ok so here we have done
the action potentials and the inputs
from another neuron so this timing like
when you sign the input from neuron a
and your addy and they sign and they
arrive at the target you run at the same
time this will induce an action
potential and target in your run another
role that coherence has is in supporting
your communications between areas so one
area region one may be responsible for a
particular attribute for example like
the color of a car and region do may be
responsible for another attribute maybe
the speed of movement so combining these
two attributes we come up with a concept
of a fast-moving red car coherence will
also have a role in the spike timing
dependent participe and can actually
induce long-term potentiation or
long-term depression so you see that
there there are many official logical
functions for coherence so we ventured
into trying to understand the
interactions between these two cortical
areas the motor cortex and the
somatosensory cortex during the
performance of
task so what we did was we implanted
microelectrode arrays what you see here
okay so it has like 96 electrodes for
this array we implanted them in the
brain in the motor cortex and the
somatosensory cortex of two monkeys and
we trade the monkeys to do a behavioral
task which is to generate a tranquility
sport so what how we train them to do is
to put to death on and apply a force on
a transducer right here to drink it in
front of their tongue and they have to
generate the force at the level tuned by
the target so this is the target over
here so they need to bring the cursor
that they see over here to the target
and that will be the amount of course
that they're supposed to generate so we
study the coherence between the primary
somatosensory and primary motor cortex
we sing the spikes and the local field
potentials so we did the spikes I
coherence so meaning despite from the
motor cortex and its coherence with the
spikes from the somatosensory cortex we
also looked at the coherence between the
spikes from the motor cortex and the
local field potentials from the
somatosensory cortex and we also looked
at the spikes from somatosensory cortex
and the local field potentials from the
motor cortex so this message of
coherence represents kind of like us for
example despite by coherence will be an
output relation of the outputs between
the two particle areas and the spikes
kill two hearings will be a relation of
them out inputs from one area and the
adults in another area so what we found
is that the coherence between neurons
and spice and local field potentials
from these two areas are actually
dynamically modulated so here I am
showing you the spiked by coherence of a
neuron affair this is a
go here Graham on the y-axis you have
the frequency which is 126 hurts and on
the x-axis we have the time relative to
the force on set so this is a behavioral
time the polar denotes the magnitude of
the coherence and you have here the
scale of the coherence so red is a
higher coherence compared to the blue so
what we see here for this neuronal bear
is that there is an increase in the
coherence of this pair right around the
fourth on set and you don't see that in
any other sign relative to the fourth on
set now we see another neuron au pair
here and we're looking at a different
frequency range which is the gamma range
specifically between 30 to 50 Hertz and
we see again an increase in the
documents in this fair around four
hundred to two hundred milliseconds fire
to force on set now we have seen this in
many pairs of neurons and in fact we
have here the mean coherence of all
nerado pairs and we showed here the
coherence in the feta to alpha range
which is statistics hurts for the theta
6 to 13 Hertz for the album and again we
see an increase in the coherence right
around for sunset and this is the mean
coherence of course all nerado's bears
for the better and gamma range and here
again is the scale the range of
frequency from 15 to 34 betta 3254 gamma
and again we see here red spots around
400 milliseconds part of course on set
and write about after force on senses
now we see the same thing in the spice
field coherence okay so now this will
remember the despite still coherence is
the relation between the spikes for one
area and the local field potentials from
the another area so the local field
potentials in an aggregate activity of
neurons surrounding your run close to
the electro that we're looking at and
here i show the coherence despite field
coherence for
single bears so this is an example of
MSF that appear so meaning that this is
a spike from motor cortex and the field
from somatosensory cortex and we see
again that dynamic modulation so it is
taz modulated and we can increase around
200 in 200 to 400 milliseconds after
force on set here we see um the spike
field coherence from neuron and iran
from the somatosensory cortex and the
local field potentials from the motor
cortex and we see the same dynamic
motivation and here again are different
examples of pairs of neurons in the
gamma range showing the same dynamic
modulation what is interesting in in
this one because we're looking at spike
field coherence is that the interactions
between these two cortical areas are
reciprocal so there is communication
coming from motor cortex so is it
somatosensory cortex and somatosensory
cortex going to the motor cortex and
here again we see the population of
neural of pairs of Sykesville coherence
again that in the network of the msf and
SMS in the theta range which is the low
frequency and in the gamma range which
is the 30 to 50 Hertz frequency so we
saw in those previous slides that
coherence is modulated by the task and
now we see that this coherence are is
exhibited in multiple frequencies ok and
there are differences though like in the
state the band which is your low
frequency you see a larger and stronger
Network compared to the alpha beta and
gamma ok so there is also coherence in
these frequencies but the the networks
are sparser and weaker and we see that
in the magnitude of the coherent here
and the same is true when we look at the
Spice Girls appearance again
this is a mini coherence which is done
magnitudes of your coherence and we see
that in the theta the coherence is much
stronger compared to the alpha beta and
gamma what is interesting in this life
though is that we see a stronger theta
coherence in the msf network as opposed
to the SMS network while in a gamma
coherence is the reverse its stronger in
the SMF network as opposed to the MSF
network now we look at the distributions
of time of decoherence so we remember in
those life in saw those red spots coming
in at different time now we looked at
the distribution of the time of the
coherence and what we see is a pattern
that is consistent of course all
networks okay so this is the spikes by
coherence this is a spike tails of
clearance between em one neuron and
somatosensory local field potentials
this is a spiketail coherence between
sensory neurons and local field
potentials from the motor cortex and all
of these networks will be a unimodal
distribution of the time of the coherent
which suggests that the theta coherence
may be related to the generation of the
bumper to support now when we look at
the grammar coherence the distribution
of the time of Q clearance is actually
bimodal to imitate two peaks pics that
are like around 500 plus or minus 500
milliseconds well give to the force on
set and we see that again consistently
across all networks with the spikes by
coherent and despite sales of hearin so
this suggests us that there are
different processes that are medicated
but I faced by the theta and gamma
coherence the gamma coherence may be
suggestive of processes concerning
sensory gating attention of processes or
maybe memory encoding
so now let's try to learn come up what
we have been looking at so we have seen
the procurement activity between these
two areas is modulated by the
behavioural task it also exhibits
frequent into the expression temporal
property as we have seen the Sun during
4th generation theta coherence is
permanent and exhibited by numbers their
signals and for the gamma for an alpha
beta and gamma coherence and you see
that this may be more related to a
sensory sensory gating attention process
because you see them prior to our after
4th generation and again the coherent
activity exhibits network specific
properties so we see that that there are
differences in the magnitude of
coherence in the bike field coherence
within motor cortex and the
somatosensory cortex so now we have been
looking at the magnitude of coherence
right so another another measure that we
get when we do a coherence analysis is
the face of the coherence the face of
the coherence tells us the lag the time
lag within a few signals ok so here and
this is just a representation of how the
different space legs are so here i show
an in-phase relationship between the two
signals so you see that the the peak of
this oscillation from from one neuron
for example or one local field potential
I'm coincides with the peak of the other
signal so we call that in space because
the face is more or less around zero
degree and then the anti face basically
out of phase when we see like the the
peak of the oscillation is it in line
with the trap of the oscillation so
there are anti face the relation the
phase lag would be plus or minus around
180 degrees and indeed when we look at
the distribution of the basis of new
to all the local field potentials that
they are coherent with we thought we saw
a neuron that showed a little bit in the
mobile distribution of anti face here
since it is plus or minus around 180
degrees and you have an example of a
neuron here which is unimodal but in
phase with the local field potential
that is coherent with now also neurons
that showed bimodal distribution of
their of their coherent space like this
neuron here and another neuron here so
coherent space can give us an
information in terms of the temporal
organization of biz network so what we
looked at is to try to see what is the
coherence space at the time of peak
coherence and so we plotted this polar
plot which is basically a particular
histogram of the distribution of the
space as big coherence in the spike
spike coherence and in these two spikes
film coherence and we see that the
distribution in the theta coherence of
your face of the coherence is bimodal
you see that consistently across all
these three networks okay so it suggests
that that's in the theta coherence we
have to sub networks so those paired
signals that manifest a bimodal
interface relation with their local
field potentials or the other or other
neurons or an anti-phase relation with
neurons and local field potentials now
we desert cities in the higher frequency
bands non-solar alpha beta and gamma so
in the spike spike coherence the gamma
distribution is uniform in the spike
tails of higher entities in the modem so
the x modality is specific to the theta
coherence
now so as I said that the face of big
data coherence could suggest us some
several organization of the sub networks
and indeed when we compared the time of
big theta coherence for this to network
Santa face at the interface we see
differences across the network ok so in
the spike spike appearance there is a
difference between the in pace and anti
face and as well in the bike field
coherence and we know that here is even
shows that the in space in the spike
spike reverence fix first right so they
have a time of people here in that
occurs first so now we can add the
properties of this coherent activity
between the two cortical areas showing
that there is a bimodal distribution of
the phase of theta coherence which
suggests so as a typing sub networks
that are involved the inflation database
on network so now we go to a kind of
like a different pin which is a spatial
pattern in the motor cortex so over the
years there have been growing interest
in the spatial patterning in the
activity of neurons in the motor cortex
and this are just like examples of
different studies that look into such
special patterning and this study
suggests that the spatial patterning of
activity in the motor cortex may relate
to some physiological functions like in
terms of eliciting activation of
specific groups of muscles example the
proximal versions of this zone or in
terms of information transfer as well so
we were very curious to see whether we
can see a special patterning of the
coherence between these two areas so we
wanted to ask a question for the spatial
location of coherent neurons influences
timing of their priests coherence
and here we look at the spatial pattern
in the artificial sensorimotor cortex I
have here a representation of the array
the microelectrode array that I showed
that the implanted is this zoom attacks
and they're snapshots of 100 millisecond
activity ok the orientation of the
square corresponds to the location in
the motor cortex and the sensory cortex
so here what i'm showing is the the
microelectrode array in the
somatosensory cortex so here this is the
evolution over time of the coherence
activity each dot would represent the
position of the new one that we're
interested in so for example so this is
a ten-by-ten to it so this neuron will
be will be will be here farther away
from the central focus so this will be
the watcher part and this will be the
lateral part so this year's will be
closer to the lateral border of their
way business will be closer to the
middle border of the rain the color of
the dots represent the timing of their
peak coherence ok so we took we took as
100 millisecond slices of this the
coherent activity and we see like some
organization starts to happen 200
milliseconds part of course content and
so we see that most of those pivot is
happening in the medial border of the
array and then and then progresses click
going laterally so such that at 400
milliseconds after horse onset activity
is exhibited by neurons located in the
lateral border of the micro- a so this
represents our some kind of a spatial
gradient ok that is moving from medial
to lateral
so now we looked at the mean spatial
gradient of that coherent activity of
these two monkeys ok so here I show the
microelectrode array to implanted from
monkey why and the microelectrode arrays
of the implanted from monkey beanie this
represents the micro elected aerated the
motor cortex the green one and the
lighter green represents a
microelectrode array implanted into
somatosensory cortex and this is a
central so close this is a roster parts
of the brain which is the lateral part
the middle part and the puzzle part so
when we average the spatial gradient so
from each of the days that we recorded
from these animals we saw a pattern
which is Ross or natural progression of
coherence activity in the motor cortex
and that is happening here for the
specified coherence and for the
spiketail coherence so this would be the
MSS meaning the spike from my from the
motor cortex and the local field
potentials from the somatosensory cortex
so we saw this in monkey y and we saw a
more wastrel progression for monkey be
just the same it's going from the
central circles was ready now when we
look at the batter in the spatial
gradient in the somatosensory cortex we
see that the gradient of the spatial
gradient is happening from video borders
to the lateral border ok so and that's
from monkey y and also for monkey be so
it's down to the video to the lateral so
what is the significance of the
direction of this spatial gradient
functionally right so in a previous
study that we have done we looked at the
activity of the motor cortex new one and
their relation to force okay and this
figure here shows a distribution it's a
bimodal distribution of the legs between
the activity of the neurons and the port
if we see here a group of neuron that
actually is leading force and another
group of neuron that is actually lagging
force okay so now we try to look at the
position of this new runs in the
microelectrode array is there some kind
of special patterning of the position of
these neurons based on their relation to
force whether they're leading force or
they're lagging force and here we see in
blue that your ones that are delighting
force and in bed the nurses are leading
force this is the microelectrode arrays
it's a 10 by 10 with this is the central
focus right here and we see that in this
shaded green light green area you see
more of the red dots they meaning like
retain more of those near ones that are
leading the force so this suggests to us
that neurons that need the ports are
located closest to the central focus and
here you see more of the blue near us
the new roses are lagging force farther
away from the central sulcus so we
thought that this could explain the
spatial gradient that we saw in the
coherent activity of m1 neurons and when
it start when it's the special green and
blue being rostral naturally I'm so
moving away starting from the central
circles and moving away from the central
focus now what could be the significance
of the spatial gradients in the
somatosensory cortex as we saw so
remember the spatial gradient is moving
from the medial border of the cortex the
somatosensory cortex and swords another
border so previous study have actually
shown that the mechanoreceptors of the
lips
they are located in the middle border of
the somatosensory cortex and the top are
the lateral border of the somatosensory
cortex now if we examine the time for
true shin tan and so we start with an
opening of the lips and then the thumb
was choosing in auras of night the
fourth so this can very well explain why
we have that spatial gradient coming
from the medial border the lateral
border so now let's try to summarize and
see what we have learned so far we have
seen that there are coherent network
between the motor cortex the
somatosensory cortex and the involve
multiple frequencies ok so we see them
in the theta in the alpha beta and gamma
band there are frequency and network
specific because we see that that in the
beta band its larger and stronger and in
the alpha beta and gamma its parser and
weaker and the think of this activity of
the local and large-scale networks may
be organized through multiple frequency
bands for different cortical practices
to operate as multiple temporal and
spatial scales so the fact that the
coherence is happening a different
frequency bands suggest to us that there
are different cortical processes that
have to be organized over time and we
saw that because we have the time of the
coherence in the theta coherence
happening around the first onset
suggests in the theta coherence maybe
more related to fourth generation and
the fact that we saw the bimodal
distribution of the time of peak
appearance in the higher frequency bands
suggesting to us that the gamma
coherence may be more related to
processes involving sensory gating
attention of memory encoding and we all
so the solution book series of
reciprocal interaction between the motor
cortex and the somatosensory cortex so
what we saw in the beginning right there
that's possibly that the motor cortex
modern a sensory processing in the sense
somatosensory cortex and somatosensory
cortex to submit the first information
to the motor cortex for successful test
performance okay so because the motor
cortex knows the kind of movement that
is want to generate because it has an
idea of the kind of sensory consequences
that this was movements will have and in
this way is able to transmit that
information to the somatosensory cortex
and prepare for that movement and in the
same way with the information coming
from the somatosensory cortex and motor
cortex can then adjust the commands that
will come so that the movement will be
more efficient and more successful we
also saw that there is information of
course there's information in the
coherence magnitude and there's also
information in the face of the
procurement if the face of the coherence
rebuild a temporal organization of sub
networks this is possibly because you
want the brain wants to organize the
activity of the neuronal assemble at
different time scale so it has that
flexibility as to call upon different
assembly ok to be active at different
times depending on the particular
function or the discipline particular
goal that the the organism has it could
be also very helpful to segregate
feed-forward and feedback influences ok
so that the behavior that we have so we
use different muscles and we need
different motor patterns and we want to
have the ability and the flexibility to
coordinate the activation of these
different assembly
and lastly we want we saw that this
current activity has a special temporal
patterns okay so we saw that in the
motor cortex in neurons that takes a
coherent affinity of motor cortex
neurons with other neurons and Ellis
beans start from the circus and going
roughly and in the somatosensory cortex
the procurement activity starts from the
middle border medial side going
naturally and and this pattern relates
to the temporal relation of the North
spiking to the pan forth and in the
somatosensory cortex it relates to the
spatial features of the neurons
receptive fields and I'd like to thank
people who helped me in this work so
definitely i'm professor mcnicholas
etapa loose and professor color bras and
[Music]
kazutaka takahashi who are also the
colors in this paper professor yeah Liam
needs to help us with the statistical
analysis and different people from the
lab that sublease lab for their help in
the analysis and also discussion of the
of the methods and animal care thank you
very much
thank you so much for your presentation
dr. arsonist Shane we want to get right
to the questions and input of the
audience so here's a reminder of how the
audience members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left if you are
unable to get to your questions due to
time constraints dr. RC McShane will be
answering submitted questions by email
so let's begin with our first question
an audience member would like to know
there is a theoretical work showing the
dependence of spikes field coherence on
the overall activity of neurons did you
control for the differences in the
firing rate which is a very interesting
one and neither actually have a slide to
answer that question so it's been a
question that I've been asked about a
lot of times here so it's true that
there is there is work there's actually
a third theoretical work suggesting the
dependence of despite field coherence on
the overall neuronal firing neuronal
activity ok and as a consequence many of
the studies have actual control for the
higher rates of their new ones trying to
use seminar firing rates when measuring
the spikes field coherence ok so this is
very good and it sounds it's an issue
that we should take care of however we
know that in the motor cortex the
neurons in the motor cortex and neurons
and somatosensory cortex have different
firing finally ok and it's
understandable because they do different
computations greater Bay to the motor
cortex is to generate movement
somatosensory cortex is to process those
sensory information
so we were we were hesitant in
controlling for the race of the of the
firing of these neurons but we wanted to
address this issue of the dependence of
spicy coherence are the differences on
the spikelets so what we did is to
verify whether we could actually see
this linear dependence so what we did is
um look here is a graph where I plotted
the weight with spikes per seconds of
neurons in the in the types of coherence
between mother neuron spikes and field
potential from the somatosensory
coordinates and the coherence ok so here
for this particular example this is just
one neuron and all the coherence it has
with different local field potentials so
here we say that there is no relation
there's no linear relation and the same
is true in them in the SMS ok so so what
we see here is that in this particular
experiment experiment we didn't see any
relation of the mean firing rate of
neurons to the spike field for clearance
ok so we were very confident that that
whatever differences in the languages in
the coherence that we see in these two
networks is because of physiological a
real physiological difference and not
just because of the artifact of
different firing priceless
thank you so much another audience
member would like to know can the
coherence between the motor similar
tomahtoes sensory areas of the cortex be
due to a common input in these areas
thank you very interesting questions yes
it is possible that the interactions
that we see between the motor cortex and
the somatosensory cortex can be
explained by a common interest to this
area right so you have here between as a
motor cortex and the somatosensory
cortex we were looking at the
interactions between these two but this
interaction may be coming from a third
party right here as a going to the
somatosensory cortex and going to the
motor cortex at the same time okay so in
one possible brain area would be the
seller ok so the thalamus could
definitely send simultaneous the inputs
both of the motor cortex and
somatosensory cortex and indeed there
are many many studies looking at salaam
of cortical connections assertively what
I've sure what we've shown you with the
results could actually be show direct
cortical cortical interactions between
the motor cortex and the somatosensory
cortex and and this is supported by
studies showing that there are dense
connection between the motor cortex and
the somatosensory cortex and that could
be the substrate for this the
communication between the motor cortex
and somatosensory cortex also because we
know that these two areas behaviorally
you know we need these two errors to
communicate in order to efficiently
produce movement that is optimal and
successful in achieving an ethical
here's a really great question how
critical is a coherent between these
areas to the control of movement yes
that is a big question right so so we do
see this interaction between these two
different cortical areas but how
important nor is this interaction so I
would say that is very important okay
but the data that i have shown you
cannot actually answer to that question
of its importance of its vitality of its
necessity and we would like to do more
research more experiment in order to
answer this question okay and what I see
is that one way of answering this
question is where we can actually
perturb the communication between these
two areas when we're performing motor
behavior ok so if indeed the coherence
the interaction between these two heirs
is vital and necessary for the
generation of movement then if we
perturb that communication we would see
its effect in the behavior so we won't
be able to probably successfully perform
a particular motor behavior or maybe it
may not be that that what you call this
and it may not be that extensive it may
just cause no some small effects it
doesn't really small effects don't
really deserve the performance of
movement so we still have to try to
answer that question with more
experimentation
there are so many wonderful questions
coming in but we only have time for one
more dr. Arthur McCain what do you think
is the significant of the differences in
the time of peak coherence across those
frequencies thank you see again that's a
very interesting question so we see that
that coherence is exhibited in the
multiple frequencies right and then we
saw that there is a difference in the
timing of the coherence it's a we in the
theta it happens very close to four
contests in the higher frequency bands
it happens like plus or minus one
hundred thirty seconds well with the
course on set so the different timing of
theta coherence may suggest that they
give the system actually that
flexibility in order to process
different cortical critical processes at
multiple scales right a multiple scales
spatial scales and temporal scale
[Music]
wonderful i would like to once again
thank you so much dr. ultimate chain for
your presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience before we
leave today well thank you to see um
thank you Susie I just want to thank
everyone in the audience for your
interest in listening to this webinar
and I'd like to thank lab whoops again
for the invitation and allow you to
speak in engineer science 3017 event
thank you very much
thank you again everyone that was dr.
Fritz erc McShane I would also like to
thank Rob roots for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through june sixteenth 2017 keep
an eye out for an email from lab root
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we encourage you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you next time you'll buy
have a great day
[Music]